Hank the hammer Goldberg how are you
Hank rich I'm really good it's a big
weekend for me and I'm looking forward
to it I hope the weather clears there so
there we have a real race okay Hank
let's get right into first of all how
you doing everything good with you
that's good good
find love I moved to Las Vegas and I'm
enjoying life here know that Hank you
not in South Florida anymore no I'm much
closer to you okay do you run in a
Musburger every now and then no okay I
don't know if there was a history or
anything like that Hank that sounded
like I might have touched a third rail
right there everything good sports book
directors here hang out with a lot of
those guys antastic
I'm working I'm working for a couple of
different networks back with the mother
Network now is there a horse race again
I love it Hank
it's just the greatest thing ever yeah
and so so you I have no idea how many
people we're reaching out to a saying
when are you gonna have a hammer on
you're gonna have Hank on and I'm like
okay we got to do it and I'm so glad
that you were free to do it and let's
get to the edge what do you think is
going to happen on Saturday at Churchill
Downs you have the floor sir well a
couple months ago I was talking to Bill
Maher who trains Tacitus the eight horse
and he told me that he had a bunch of
Derby prospects this was the best
because he was bred to run the mile and
a quarter and he was going to train him
up to this race this was right before he
he won the Tampa Bay Derby and he said
the longer they go the better he runs
well in the wood
he got slammed coming out of the gate
and went to his knees and he passed 11
horses and won the race going away and I
thought that race really helped him
because he ran against 11 horses and
passed them all so he has that
experience and he's a horse that comes
from off the pace and builds very high
on them and I certainly trust bill Bob
the other horse I like is improbable
number 5 he drew great he freaked out
and the gate and the Arkansas
and I ran second Omaha Beach
they almost scratched him because they
put blinkers on him and he went nuts and
engaged and but he ran and he almost
caught Omaha Beach who was going to be
the favorite in this race before he
scratched this horse is doing very well
I talked to his people from windstar
Elliott Walden who runs that and Elliott
said this worse don't pay any attention
to anybody says his horses and bred to
go the distance his sire has many horses
who can run anywhere from five days to
the Derby distance and I think he drew a
great post post five I'll have a shorter
run and a lot of the other courses that
people like here and and I think that I
think he's going to get a perfect trip
from a five post and I think he's got a
great shot to win this race so those are
my two top horses you know the other
Baffert horse by the way yes laughter
this is a Baffert horse improbable the
other scheme winner and raster worst
game-winner he's the favorite he was
number 16 I didn't like his post yes a
tendency his last couple of races he's
been wide and he drifts in the stretch
and he if he had been in post 16 that
would have bothered me now with the
scratches he's out of the 14 hole which
isn't as bad but he's still wide and I
think you have to use them in your
exotics because it could be the best
horse he's really loaded with talent
when you witness before before you get
on there Hank when you say exotics what
does that mean for some folks who might
not know what you mean that there's got
to be in your exotics that is exactas
trifectas got it super plexus where you
can make a lot of money
sure instead of just betting one horse
got it okay so why don't I keep going
that's a couple of other horses
underneath code of honor Sigma ke source
R and a closing third in the Florida
Derby against a load speed
worse who had an easy trip and that was
maximum security who won't have an easy
trip in Kentucky there because he's
right next to her coma who will probably
run with him early and so a code of
honor will be closing and the wiseguy
horse is the three horse who is you know
he's he's a winner of the race in
Louisiana v the Derby there what do you
mean by wiseguy you're talking about by
my standards all the rumors about who's
doing well and if you want a real long
shot to throw in there okay
this is a horse that could hit the board
okay don't like him to win but I think
he's going to move out with the five
horse early he has a similar stalking
style and the horse is called by my
standards and and that's what I'm in a
box the 5 and the 8 okay with the 13 the
16 and the 3 inexact is and I play a
super with the 8 on top okay of the of
the other four and I'll use a super with
the 5 on top of before that I like so
and hopefully you make the score okay
there you go see you boxing the 5 and
the 8 and then if you want to add a
third right there it's either 13 16 3
and you do all three of them and then
the super is 8/5 13 16 3 or 5 8 13 16 3
that's the way you're going right here
right and you know what you've got to
use the 16 he's a very good horse but
he's he's been wide as last two trips
and ran second and and if he runs why
here you know he you don't want to add
any extra distance we're gonna go on a
mile and a quarter and that's where I
what I think could hurt him but yeah you
have to use him and your exacta boxes so
Hank over here on the Rich Eisen show
the scratching of Omaha Beach changed
this race how well he was a favorite and
it's a wet track he loves you off going
he would he would have had a difficult
time getting in a position to get the
early lead because there were the two
speed horses I mentioned inside and a
lot of stalking pace and he might not
have had an easy time getting the lead
that I was going to use him in my exact
of boxes but I not on top I thought he
could be beaten I you know he's
benefited in his last couple of races by
you know the the off track he loved the
slop in Arkansas and the fact that Mike
Smith chose him over roadster and that's
when the odds dropped on them yeah I'm
looking at the weather right now for
Saturday Hank it's a high probability of
rain coming 70 percent it's gonna be a
lot of ruin huh yeah a lot of ruin is
arranged
early right the the track gets pretty
dry too hurrying okay and but the one
thing is about the racing there today
and tomorrow is if it's if it's sloppy
and the turf course is is yielding at
all yes
the rail is not where you want to be you
want to be outside
okay so then that would help game-winner
Haywood right okay
all right so let's let's sum up here
Hank Oberg you like for somebody just
wants to box something you like the 5
and the 8 horse and then if somebody has
the one shot at boxing a trifecta out of
the 13 16 and 3 to throw in there which
one would you suggest probably the 16 so
then you want game-winner so if the 5 8
16 is your trifecta of choice and then
again the superfecta would just be some
combination of all 5 certainly with the
8 and 5 on top or the 5 & 8 on top of
the 13 16 and 3 that's the way you're
rolling yep going to I'm going to use
exact is with with the 3 and the 13 okay
and the 5 in the air okay I like it
alright where you gonna watch the race
I'm gonna give a shout-out to we're
gonna watch it
I'm gonna be at Sunset Station to watch
your races but I have to be home because
the network I work for wants me on
before the race and they want to bring
me on afterwards thank this is awesome
and that's where my Skype setup is okay
so I have to be home to watch the race
all right there you go all right
do you have any other questions Chris if
I have I covered everything with Hank do
you think no we're locked in let's do
this Hank okay let's do this thing we're
gonna do this Hank anything else I
should know what's going on well I like
the 14 horse in the Oaks today okay
because there's a lot of speed there
nice bonus and and I think this horse of
a name is a horse's Restless rider and I
think she's the one closer that I like
in the race okay and and you know we
haven't seen the only time we've ever
seen back-to-back Triple Crown winners
is a course of Seattle Slew and affirmed
77 and 78 if you had to name one horse
that has the best chance to do that it
would be game-winner would you say no it
would be Tacitus okay because if he wins
this race he's going to be perfectly as
mad as my told me that the longer they
go the better reruns so you know I like
him a lot in this relation and and I
think he'd be a big threat in the
Belmont because I was running style and
his ability to go the distance
he has great breeding well Hank Suzy
says sends her best to you too because I
I got chala but she's terrific I agree
you and I are lockstep there too well
chat with you before the Preakness okay
we'll chat again okay tell her the
reason I haven't sent her any stone
cribs that's because I'm in Las Vegas
yeah well we'll just come to see you
we'll just have dinner at some point
we'll do that that would be wonderful my
great I get a lot I get a lot of comps
here is so it's not a bad deal look I
love that you Hank the way you roll I am
sure you get a lot of cops walk did you
do you ever see Sinatra there in Vegas
did you ever see a Sinatra show yet
which one I did which one do you
remember I saw much I saw him at Caesars
years ago I saw more than once
and I used to see him
the Fountainbleu it but in Miami Beach
I'm sure he worked there well they have
the some of the most famous photographs
of him strolling around the pool there
with a with all of his compatriots at
some of my favorite who I watch the
races with the Shecky Greene who's over
90 and still mentally sharp and he meets
me at the race book and he's got some
great Sinatra stories I bet I once saw
him with my parents in the Catskills
Hank oh it's a fact that is a fact and
also at the Friars Club I once saw him
personally true story
honey band and no doubt Hank will chat
before the Preakness we'll chat soon for
sure it's great to talk readers right
back at you that's the hammer right
there Hank over for more of the Rich
Eisen show tune - audience Channel 239
on DirecTV for free on BR live or
download the Rich Eisen show app